hey there Gary this is Boris from Turkey
I'm Maria and I'm from Mexico hello my
name is Dimo and I'm from Bulgaria hi
Gary it's Peg Moore from Bronx New York
my name is Liz Peralta Foxwell and I'm
from the best Borough Brooklyn on your
birthday I wanted to share something
with you I want to tell you a story
about something kind that I did during
the summer the other day I was riding my
bike and I let a man walk by before me
and uh yeah I feel great I've been going
through some some health problems this
year and it's been hard to find
Specialists and she was telling her
doctor that I'm going through seeing the
similar things and he volunteered to
reach out to me to help treat me and see
me virtually completely free of charge
you give something and you do something
nice and you shall receive something
nice I had been through my favorite
sticker store and I found the really
really cool Cristiano Ronaldo sticker
one of my favorite players obviously I
was really happy about that I was
traveling back home by train and at one
of the stops I didn't hit along with his
sister and his grandfather got on the
train he told me how he wants to become
a footballer he was actually wearing a
Cristiano Ronaldo Jersey I just knew
that I had to give him my sticker even
though I loved it once I saw the glow in
his eyes I just knew I had done the
right thing you can just be kind to
People by sharing your food or sharing
your time that's in my opinion the
biggest act of kindness like to teach
others to treat others that way the
story I'll share with you is actually
something that Gary himself did
something kind for me my kindness story
is around Gary also and the person that
was really kind to me was a video two
three years ago I used to be someone who
taught that kindness is weakness and
you're the person who changed that to me
back in 2000 I think was 13 or 14 when
he was doing this interview a day thing
I somehow got on the list he said yes
and then I stopped doing it before it's
my turn fast forward six seven years
later not only did he make up for that
with an appearance on My podcast because
it was sure he agreed to come back and
do it again strictly out of the kindness
of his own heart so an act of kindness
that had a pretty huge impact on me was
actually observing you last year you had
just come out of having a difficult
conversation related to your family in
your office you know we we could even
tell like it probably wasn't your best
day of your life and I just remember
observing the way you interacted with
like the Savannah employee that was here
from another office that really wanted
to meet you you know you greeted her as
well as you greet anyone you took
pictures with her you were smiling it
takes a lot of internal strength to you
know be feeling maybe a little bad but
not let that negativity spread to others
I met up with Gary in Romania and he had
been up for 36 hours and even though as
tired as he was he helped this older
lady carry her bag onto the plane and I
wasn't even recording it or anything so
like it was definitely not like for the
camera or anything like that he was just
doing it because just being a nice
person although always remember that
that's why I very much celebrate Gary's
act of kindness with others because he's
sharing and spreading kindness like in
real in a real way I also wanted to
thank you because you are not only
helping people to become better in their
businesses and careers but you are also
helping them to become better people I
just want to tell you about these two
beautiful people
but I would not have known them without
be friends Sal de Guardia and Amanda the
guardian
gifted me my trip to vcon last year
Hotel airfare I just had the most
wonderful time and I wouldn't have
gotten there without them I actually
just wanted to shout out my guidance
counselor from back in the day Mrs Weiss
she actually helped me to be seen and
validated and heard and she was just an
awesome person hi Gary I hope you're
having a great birthday
um I have a story about kindness from
our very own Dustin during the summer
months when it was brutally hot out I
didn't have an air conditioning unit so
just out of the kindness of his heart
without taking anything
um drove an air conditioning unit from
his house in New Jersey all the way to
the city to me and refused to take
anything it just was a simple act of
kindness that meant so much to me when I
think of a moment where someone has been
kind to me I think about when I lost my
mom it was sudden and it was really hard
because she was young she was 40. I
thought my world was going to end and
and what happened was that I had this
whole community of people that came to
help me to have a shoulder to cry on to
support me in the hardest of times and
so that Boatman taught me that we can
have millions of dollars we can have all
the cool clothes but at the end of the
day the thing that's most important is
the community we surround ourselves with
because in the hardest moments they're
going to be the people who lift you up
and in The Most Beautiful Moments
they're going to be the people who cheer
you on with that special song and I'm
just so grateful to be part of this
community be friends because it's that
extended times a million happy birthday
thank you I love you and remember not to
shake the five man hey garyvee happy
birthday I can't think of a better way
to honor this man uh than to say thank
you and happy birthday TV happy birthday
hey Gary happy birthday just want to
wish you a happy birthday G happy
birthday Gary a happy birthday Gary I
hope you have an amazing amazing day a
huge happy birthday to you Gary man Gary
I hope you have the best birthday ever
and I love you very much happy birthday
Gary I wish you the happiest birthday
love you hey Gary happy birthday happy
birthday guy I love you thanks so much
for everything you've given me Gary I
hope you have a beautiful birthday
because your existence has made such a
difference in the lives of so many
people love you so much take care bye